lauren how are we doing uh pretty good
how are you i'm doing well i'm doing
well how can i help this morning
um well my question's about boundaries
and how to cope if
people or a person a particular person
won't respect those boundaries
so my father was sexually abusive when i
was a child
and i i hadn't really told anyone as
like as a kid but i knew that
whenever i was an adult that and i had
some power that
i would do something about it and that
he
wouldn't be able to do anything to us
anymore so now as an adult
my husband and i have set up boundaries
for him but he doesn't really respect
those
we've moved the boundaries further and
further away just to protect
our kids because if he's already
stepping over the boundary we want to
make sure that
that stepping over doesn't affect our
children
but now at this point we've moved him
far enough away that he's supposed to
not be contacting us at all
but he still does and then he's getting
more sneaky about it
so he'll write us letters but not put a
return address on it or
try to get my brothers to contact us so
this has been going on for about five
years so i'm not really sure
if we can expect him to ever change or
if maybe there's something
that we can i don't know that i can
implement to help me cope it it really
bothers me a lot
yeah whenever he does that yeah um so
i'm gonna go all the way back
and there are two people on planet earth
that
were given the singular task of making
sure you were loved and connected
and one if not both of them utterly and
drastically
not only failed that but they scorched
that and i want to tell you
on behalf of your community and your
friends i'm sorry that happened that
sucks
dads are not supposed to abuse their
daughters no
okay yeah
and i don't want to blame your mom i
don't know that situation and we don't
have time for that
but um
moms are supposed to be there to protect
their daughters too
okay and i want you to know all of that
sucks and i'm sorry that happened
second when you came out and talked
about this
what happened when did you decide to
talk about it
i actually didn't i my husband and i
started having kids and
um we started having daughters so so
every alarm you have in your
heart and mind set off right oh yeah
yeah as soon as we found out we were
having girls it was
yeah we knew we had to do something and
so i we lived a long ways away from them
so i just we just had set up that he
wasn't allowed to come visit
and if he did he wasn't allowed to stay
at our house and he had to be around the
kids
only with us in the room we felt like we
could do a good job there but
after we had our second daughter my
husband was at work
was going to go back to work and i was
about to go back to work so i asked my
mom to come and help
when i went back to work and he then of
course
jumped in real quick and said he would
love to come up and help
and watch our girls and then no no no no
no
yeah well and i we have never said
anything so
and i feel like i just don't have a lot
of courage whenever it comes to him so i
just texted him
and told him he wasn't welcome where we
were and then he
apparently was confused and showed the
text to my mom
who had kind of maybe had an inkling
that something had gone on when i was a
kid but
she started quickly putting two and two
together so so listen
then it all came out your your
voice the words you were using are
classic
um language of somebody who has been
abused and traumatized by someone who
was supposed to love him
okay and do not
please please don't beat yourself up for
things like courage for things like
feeling afraid
for things like feeling hurt
please let yourself off the hook for
that there is a little girl inside of
you that is still trying to protect you
okay and i want you to know she's done
her job
and it's time for her to go lay down
okay okay okay
and when you feel that feeling of and
your heart starts racing really hard
and you feel like you need to have a
hard conversation and you just
start to flinch i want you to exhale and
say
thank you sweetheart i've got it from
here and
that's when the rage-filled lauren can
show up
the adult lauren who will burn a house
down for her baby girls
right then she can show up okay
okay um
so boundaries are important and we i
talk about boundaries a lot
our friend henry cloud the master the
guy who wrote the literally wrote the
book called boundaries
talks a lot about the importance of
drawing boundaries
this is different this is nuclear
this is you will stay so far the hell
away from my family
and my children that if you sneeze in
this direction i'll call the cops on you
and i'll call him again
and i'll call him again yeah and here's
the thing i would
i just don't know he just seems like
he's not listening to that
that he people who are broken in the way
that he's broken and you if you've
listened to me enough you know i don't
like to use that term
child child predators people who prey on
children
people who abuse children sexually
they only respond to power that's it
yeah and they don't get inklings
because an inkling is a crack in the in
the concrete that they can slither into
they don't get suggestions because
suggestions
they they feel like vulnerability and
someone who preys on children
preys on vulnerability yeah
and so your brothers have you sat down
and had a real direct
hard conversation with them um well
i've told them everything because my
other brother also has a daughter
okay um they i feel like
they didn't know until about five years
ago and their world kind of came
crashing down i don't i haven't told
them what to do i've been trying to let
them kind of navigate that
have you have you explicitly told them
what happened
i emailed them i told them everything
okay yeah good for you
i felt like i had to yeah i sent it to
both of them and i said i don't ever
want to talk about it again
you need this story is your story and
nobody is allowed to ask you questions
and force you to answer things you don't
want to answer this is your story your
narrative your world okay
um and i want you to always feel in
control of that narrative and when you
don't
that's when you have control of part two
which is i'm walking away
okay okay so yeah um you control
the story okay but your brothers may
need some coaching
and as you mentioned if they had
idolized this man
and they had pumped him up and suddenly
they found something out about him
then they might need some guidance
however embarrassing that is
i wish they wouldn't need guidance i
wish they would have men in their life
that they could sit down and talk to who
would be straight with them
but here's the guidance that disgusting
man will never be involved in our family
get-togethers
if he knows where we are i am not going
to be there because my job is to protect
my heart and mind and my soul and my
daughters
your husband is going to step up and
help too because his job is to
love and honor and walk alongside and
protect you
and his daughters right and there is no
word mincing moving forward and i'm not
telling you what to do
i hope i'm empowering you that that
little girl can
finally lay down and go play like she's
supposed to
yeah and freaking most the time
i live great like that my husband's
great and we live
a ways away from him but just even just
a couple
of maybe two weeks ago that's my
brothers came and said well what are we
supposed to say to dad whenever he
asked about you and i was like why is he
asking about me
he knows he's not supposed to have
anything to do with me but i was like
why do you even have to ask
yes i told them that they should tell
him to ask me
if they're if he wanted to know
something and he knows he's not allowed
to contact me but
so here's the thing give them a couple
of words to use which is
he y'all are not to speak on my behalf
to that disgusting person
my hope is that you would never talk to
him
he cashed out his father card
he gave it up yeah and he has done
nothing to redeem it nothing
no right no yep and so
um i would tell your brothers i don't
want to have a conversation with you
about that man
ever again ever and if any of you guys
give him our address
if you send him any photos of his
granddaughters
then i'm done with y'all too because you
have chosen a side
that is not one that i'm comfortable
with and there's a period at the end of
that sentence
okay and here's the thing i need you to
hear me directly when i say this
there wasn't something wrong with you as
a baby girl there was something wrong
with him
yeah there is nothing wrong with your
boundaries now
the problem remains with him okay and i
want to honor your brothers i know it's
confusing and it's easy on this side of
the fence to be like they should just do
it's hard i get that
but your brothers have a responsibility
and they need to get it done
okay do you think if my dad had any
chance of ever
ever being redeemed like ever coming do
people like this
ever come around and if they ever would
what
i kind of felt like he might have to hit
rock bottom which is lose absolutely
everything
if he was ever going to look inside of
himself
but i thought that maybe he'd have to
lose his whole family
i believe strongly i mean the
cornerstone of why i do what i do is
because i believe in redemption
i believe there is no one person who
cannot
with the help of a lot of other people
and
um with god and a lot of strength and a
lot of support
often professional help can't claw their
way back i believe that
i also know the data that says
adult men who abuse young children
have a very very hard road back if they
ever want to come back
and it starts with a getting on your
face in the mud
and begging for forgiveness and being
completely honest and open and then
seeing
professional help for years and still
i'm
never gonna leave that person alone with
my daughters period
no right i'm not gonna have that person
to my house period
the relationship is forever altered
because of what they did
because of who they chose to be not you
and those who do that are master guilt
trippers
you are the ones screwing up christmas
you're the one that wrecked my marriage
um you're the one that screwed up my
relationship with my sons
bull crap he did
what you are having to do is put the
fire out that he
lit and that means you have to stand on
the front yard with the hose and get
everything wet
and he set the roof on fire but you're
having to douse the pictures and the
couches
and the piano and the guitars you're
dusting everything because of a fire he
lit
and what abusers do is they stand in the
front yard and say why did you get my
pictures all wet
because you set the fire dude right so
i do believe in redemption that is not
your story to walk
no i my brothers just ask and i
told them that i'm not the one who can
help him i know that for sure
and they're not the ones who can help
him either you don't think they can do
anything
absolutely not they they keep thinking
they they're like well
i had asked him to go to counseling this
was myself years ago
and he went for like two two times and
he said it was way too hard it made him
cry he was so
sad
yes there she is
and then he quit so then that was when
we decided there was no hope for us
then he's a coward he is a coward and
he's not willing to do the work so is
there redemption possible for him
yep is he willing to do it nope no
okay nope okay and that is not something
your brothers can do
and i appreciate their heart man they
love their old man and they're trying to
rack their brains
i can't believe this happened um
but it is what it is okay what they can
do
and brothers out there listening to this
there are moments when our parents blow
our minds
i cannot believe my dad did that
here's their choice and i and if you
listen to my show at all you also know i
don't like binary choices either ors
i'm giving you an either or they can
choose
to double down on their sister
and to reconnect with you because you
probably have years and miles of pain
and disconnection that you're
gonna be healing from for the rest of
your life and they can
love you and every time they reach out
to you and say hey what about dad
it hurts because you don't even have the
words for it and your body
falls apart from the inside out and
you're like what
and then you look in the mirror and
think you're crazy
yeah and so what they can do is they can
let him know
you hurt our family you imploded our
family because of your sickness
because of your choices to abuse our
sister
and my guess is you aren't the only one
that's my guess yeah i hope not but yeah
i know i know the statistics but yeah
and so he chose that and until he
chooses
to get a man to take to feel
uncomfortable
in counseling um for a couple of decades
he should be in jail quite honestly and
what i'll tell you this
here's here's a hard thing and we can
wrap the call up
okay the hard thing is this
if you know that he has access to kids
i will go to the police you have to
report i will go to the newspaper
i will tell everyone in the entire world
i've already
run it through my mind but running it
through your mind and actually doing it
are two different things
i would do it i already know for sure
that i would do it but
he did try once to have some kids around
him and my brothers completely flipped
out
and of course and then he stopped
flipping out is that step that's step
one a
step one b two three four and five is
calling the police
and you think i should call the police
if he even makes
like do you think i should have called
the police back whenever he
got a girlfriend who had granddaughters
yes
i i don't know when to yes i do i do
okay i absolutely do all right
and i don't have a lot of quarter for
this situation at all
okay um but yes and
if he reaches out to you i would call
the police if if he has a restraining
order if you have a straight order
against him i'd call the police
if he gets in contact with your brothers
and wants to go visit them and their
kids i'll call the police
and i would tell your brothers every
time i know that he's at your house
around kids i'm gonna call the police
okay if you want to make a police record
about your childhood
depending on what your state you're in
there may not even be a statute of
limitations on that deal
there's not i already looked that might
give you
a step towards healing because he's not
getting the message
yeah and every time he tries to ask
about you it's a power move
every time he sends you a letter it's a
power move
okay and he will only respond to
somebody look at me
do i i kind of thought i said i kind of
thought about being like you won't leave
us alone we should tell the police but
then i thought they just laughed because
it was like
he sent you a letter ma'am you're fine i
don't know
if you go to a sex crime investigator
who knows what they're doing and you go
to a sex crimes advocate
who knows what historical trauma does to
to children
and how that ricochets through their
life for the rest of their life
they'll hear you and they won't laugh at
you okay
they'll honor you they'll honor your
story and
at at best they can go to his house
and go through his stuff and open an
investigation
at worst they've got him on record yeah
so if he shows up at somebody else's
house again
then people can get involved okay
all right but i want you here's the
thing though you don't have to
yell and scream and fuss and fight this
is your story and your narrative
if you see see that he's around kids you
do you have a responsibility
i'm putting that on you but i will um i
want you to
never lose control of the narrative
again
of your story of who you choose to tell
it to how you choose to tell it that's
yours
okay okay you've had enough people in
your life take your power away
yeah and i'm glad that you got a husband
who loves you you got two baby girls
that
you you love dearly and
um i hope that you can
can be honest and direct with your
brothers in a way that they can now
understand
oh we've got to pick okay we've got to
take a side
okay all right is that cool
hey thank you for trusting me with a
call yeah thank you
that was helpful you're a brave brave
woman lauren
and you've got a long road of healing i
want you to make sure
you are doing the work to be healed too
make sure you get with a good trauma
therapist who can walk alongside you
give you some tools for when that spins
up in you
give you some tools to walk alongside if
you do choose to call the police on your
dad
who will walk alongside you and may even
be in the room with you when you decide
to meet with your brothers
may give you some language to talk to
your husband and more importantly give
you some language to talk to yourself
but as i started the call i want you to
let that little girl who's been
protecting you for years and years and
years i want you to let her go out and
play
and i want you to let that healing begin